PHIL: One person is going to
win, and they can choose to
bring along somebody
of their choice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Last time in 5.301,
the students just practiced
re-crystallization.
Now it's time for
the real thing.
PROFESSOR: You're actually going
to take your crystals,
and you're going to
re-crystallize them, to
produce one big crystal.
And there's a prize.
Whoever gets this first is
going to lunch with me at
Legal Sea Foods, and you can
bring one of your friends, and
you can invite the TAs.
NARRATOR: The goal is to grow
a single, perfect, crystal.
But first, the students have to
actually make the compound
they're going to grow
their crystals from,
this chromium complex.
This is their first real
reaction in the lab.
ANTHONY: It's a different
color and that's usually
pretty good in chemistry.
NARRATOR: After they filter,
wash, and dry their product,
the students begin testing
solvents, and some start
teaming up.
PHIL: I actually saw an alliance
forming over here.
YI-SHIUAN: I saw some
of them split up
trying different solvents.
We actually worked on find
the solvents together.
JULIE: We decided to use
dichloromethane and hexane for
our solvents.
ANTHONY: We're going to use
hexanes and methanol.
Shh.
We're going to win.
NARRATOR: Hansol seems
pretty driven.
HANSOL: I like competition.
I want to win, obviously.
NARRATOR: If you win, who will
you invite to lunch?
HANSOL: I would probably
pick Dan.
I made a deal with
him earlier.
NARRATOR: So, Hansol's been
working with Dan.
What about you, Emily?
EMILY: Yeah, I worked with Dan
to figure out what solvent
system would work well.
NARRATOR: Uh, OK.
Let's recap.
HANSOL: Dan.
EMILY: Dan.
EMILY: Dan
HANSOL: Dan.
EMILY: Dan.
NARRATOR: Dan, what do you
have to say for yourself?
DAN: It was a loosely
formed alliance, we
didn't sign any papers.
NARRATOR: Ike meanwhile
has a different idea.
IKE: I'm broke.
If I get the ticket I'm going
to sell it for money.
Because I know, these suckers
want it really bad.
PHIL: We have some people whose
samples look pretty good.
They seem to be wanting to try
a lot of different solvent
systems, a lot of different
temperatures.
They're asking a lot
of questions.
They want to make sure that
everything is perfect.
Because I think everyone wants
to get the biggest crystal.
They're very determined.
They're going for
all or nothing.
They don't want a bunch
of small crystals.
LINA: Next week, we're going
to win the biggest crystal
competition.
Because the winners get to take
the TAs and Professor
Dolhun out to lunch.
JULIE: Legal Sea Foods,
for free.
NARRATOR: So that's it.
Everything's set and everyone's
excited about the prize.
But, who will win?
Find out next time on 5.301.
JULIE: Yeah, we're done.
PHIL: I'm having this
re-occurring dream.
It's like I'm jogging through
a park with a
fitness boot camp.
And I stop to talk
to Kris Jenner.
And I always say, no, no,
no, Kris, I can't talk
to you right now.
And she pours Kool-Aid on me.
And I wake up drenched
in Kool-Aid.
That's a dream.
If it was Bruce Jenner pouring
Kool-Aid on me, that would be
a nightmare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]